[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily the family of
missing woman kathleen mccormick durst
accuses a multi-billion dollar real
estate family of helping cover up her
murder for decades
and the judge now saying robert durst's
murder trial is full steam ahead
despite the defendant suffering from
cancer the question is not whether he
can endure
the rigors of the trial the question is
whether he can survive at all
why no one is facing charges for a tiger
missing for more than a week
and how the big cat was finally found i
think the public thought it'd be easy
to catch a tiger but it wasn't at all
plus
a florida jury deliberating the fate of
a former deputy accused
of planting drugs on unsuspecting
motorists we break down closing
arguments in the trial
of zachary western you gotta wonder
what's in someone's head a deputy's head
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the murder trial of the millionaire real
estate air has resumed as new
allegations against robert durst are
being levied by the family of his
missing wife
he murdered her and it was a
premeditated murder there was absolutely
no question about it kathleen mccormack
durst was last seen at the new york home
she shared with her husband robert durst
in 1982.
her family believes durst had a role in
her assumed murder but her body was
never found
their family attorney held a virtual
press conference just an hour before
dirt's trial for the murder
of his best friend was set to resume and
accused durst's father and brother
of helping to cover up kathy's murder
what type of person
remains quiet when their sister-in-law
is brutally murdered
according to a motion filed by the
prosecution douglas durst knew his
brother was stealing hundreds of
thousands of dollars
from their family business the durst
organization is a new york real estate
company
worth billions of dollars prosecutors
are now saying the alleged theft could
have played a role in kathy's
disappearance
and tie it to the murder of his best
friend susan berman
susie berman said the police of contact
los angeles police are contacting me
they want to talk to me about her kathy
durst disappearance
when susan berman told him that you know
what
i'm going to talk to investigators
that she sealed her faith robert durst
trial for berman's murder was halted
last year
due to the pandemic ten witnesses took
the stand including one of kathy's
friends
who said under cross-examination by the
defense that kathy was terrified of
dearth's father
seymour i was worried that the father
was going to kill her
remember saying that that yes i did
yes now 78 the defense says durst
suffers from bladder cancer and other
ailments that prevent him from actually
participating at trial
he spends more than 90 of his time on
his back
in a bed a hospital tight bed he's
anemic
he has spinal disease he has kidney
stones
it's a myriad of conditions there's not
two systems of justice in this county
one for rich people and one for
everybody else
mr durst is in custody and getting the
best
treatment possible that they offer at
county usc
at the medical center at the jail the
judge denied the motion for an
indefinite stay of trial
saying durst is able to clearly think
since he wrote a letter to the judge
earlier this year the defense has had at
least five years to prepare for
every contingency in this case second of
all
there is no evidence that mr durst is
mentally incompetent
indeed his letter to this court
clearly demonstrates his cogent
thought the 23 people who served on the
jury will be brought in for orientation
the judge will ask them if they have
seen any news about the case if they
have discussed the case with anyone and
if they have any health concerns that
could prevent them from serving
also briefly mentioned in court was a
letter one of the jurors apparently
submitted
you said about the juror who had written
the note
yeah i did
[Music]
your honor two things i assume uh the
court is going to let us know
obviously um the juror does not make
determinations about
the legal admissibility of the state
we'll talk about how to install it
after jury orientation each side will
have two hours to recap their opening
statements
and any testimony they deem important
from last year
joining us today is law and crime host
and criminal defense attorney linda
kenny baden
and terry austin linda the judge looks
like he's moving forward no matter
what and also was abram's presser
everything he made it out to be
well brian let's talk about the first
question first okay
this judge made it clear to the defense
and to the public
that robert durst can be wheeled in on
his back on a hospital bed
he can be wheeled in on a casket and a
matter of fact if need be
they'll have the trial in the morgue
because he is going to trial in this
courtroom in los angeles
no matter what happens i mean they just
say that that was
very very very clear uh the second
regarding
attorney abram's press conference who
represent certain members of the family
you remember he has sued
deborah sharatan who was the second wife
of robert durst he is suited for
defamation
he's had a number of pressers he didn't
really
tell us anything new we know that
according to one of
kathy mccormick's friends kathy
mccormick durst
friends that she may have been
threatening
to reveal his criminal conduct to the
family
however that doesn't mean the family was
concealing because it doesn't mean the
family even
knew about it at that time so i don't
think that went very far
yeah it's not the smoking gun we were
expecting it's information we kind of
already knew to begin with
right now the question is how they're
going to tie that into the trial uh
terry
the judge is starting with quote unquote
jury orientation
and motions to delay you saw him there
that he denied
the motion to delay due to durham's
health uh what does the restart of this
case look like
you know what brian trying to reorient
this jury is
almost like picking a new jury in terms
of how long it's going to take
it's been a year so of course they've
talked about the case
it's been a year so of course they've
discussed the case
and they've seen news about it so i
think having to go through all of that
asking all of these jurors multiple
questions is
not a waste of time of course he has to
do it because now we have this jury that
has been sitting for a year and having
to listen to the openings again
two hours each it was torture the first
time it's going to be
double torture this time and honestly
i think that the fact that this jury has
to remember
evidence we've had 10 witnesses have you
said having to remember that evidence
this to me is grounds for appeal i think
long ago they should have said okay
start over
new jury because that's what would be
fair to the defendant
yeah definitely grounds for appeal the
14-month break in between
the having i mean i've never seen it
linda i'm not sure if you've ever seen
it
doing like this new kind of opening
statements i think it could get
overturned an appeal
the problem is is robert durst going to
make it through that appeal
i think it might be a moot point at some
point with the bladder cancer and other
health restrictions that he has but
we'll keep eyes on it and see how that
plays out of course law and crime
has our cameras in there and we'll be
following this
trial uh until the very end thank you
both
still ahead on law and crime daily when
will former brooklyn center police
officer kim potter
stand trial for the death of dante
wright but first the big cat has been
found in the space city
where the tiger on the loose is now and
hear from carol baskin on the police
involvement
[Music]
next
[Music]
welcome back the search is over for a
missing tiger in houston
and police say no one is facing charges
for the big cat on the loose
commander it's been a long week for
looking for this guy
[Music]
indy the tiger missing for nearly a week
has been found we got him
and he's healthy houston police say the
tiger wandered away from a home
rented by victor cuevas an off-duty
deputy testified in court that he saw
cuevas
grab the tiger by the collar kiss on the
forehead and take it into the house
cuevas is accused of fleeing shortly
thereafter cats seemed to be wandering
around for a long time before anybody
came out the front door
looking for it so that tells me they
didn't even know this cat was
loose big cat lover carol baskin says
that india is just nine months old
and weighs 175 pounds fully grown
india could get up to 600 pounds when it
went outside
it like laid down in the grass like oh
this is so
amazing and when we rescue big cats we
see that all the time because they've
been kept
inside buildings or on concrete floors
because it's easy to hose off
they've never felt what it means to be a
tiger and to connect with the earth
and the way they react to that first
opportunity is exactly like what i saw
in that cap
crevasse's attorney told us that another
man owns the cat
but police say cuevas's wife gia is the
owner cuevas was arrested for fleeing
but india remained on the lamb until an
animal shelter received a tip on
saturday from a concerned citizen
that citizen was in contact with the gia
who is the pet owner and
she wanted to turn the tiger over to us
police say they allowed gia to go with
them
to the animal shelter because she was
under stress he was later taken to the
wildlife sanctuary outside of dallas
he was in a very small crate when he was
brought to us today
and as you can tell he's in a much
bigger crate now and he seems to be
doing fine
houston police are reminding people that
tigers should not be kept in houses as
pets
now to minnesota where there is a
hearing for the former police officer
accused of shooting and killing donte
wright
former brooklyn center officer kim
potter appeared in court for a pre-trial
hearing
the hennepin county judge determined
there was enough evidence to proceed
with a trial and set her trial date for
december 6 2021
potter is charged with second-degree
murder for the death of dante wright
during a traffic stop on body camera
video potter can be heard yelling
i'm going to tase you before she fired
her gun instead of her taser
potter was a police officer for 26 years
before she resigned
briefly after the incident she is
currently out of jail on bond
back with us as criminal defense
attorney and host linda kenny boden
and terry austin the hearing seem to be
mostly about probable cause in pre-trial
hearings
terry where or why do you think the
judge found probable cause here
well you know this was an omnibus
hearing they have the right to listen to
all of the evidence and then the judge
makes the determination whether there
is probable cause for this man slaughter
two charge and for that she has to see
that there is
culpable negligence which created an
unreasonable risk
she probably looked at the video i'm
certain of that and
listened to actually what kim potter was
saying her words where she said i'm
going to use the taser and her words
where
she actually said taser taser taser so
all of that
probably went into the determination and
i'm certain she looked at the police
policy she probably
looked at the training that potter
herself actually had
to come to a final determination that
there was probable cause
for this manslaughter to charge and just
a reminder there are different standards
it's not the same standards we'll see at
trial beyond a reasonable doubt
a little bit different than the grand
jury of preponderance and the evidence
this is
probable cause somewhere in between a
little bit lower than what we're
typically seeing in trials
linda admissibility of work records
training guidelines witness statements
what kind of pre-trial arguments do you
think that need to be hashed out in this
case
well obviously all the above but the
defense let me tell you from the defense
point of view
they're going to try to limit her
training records if indeed
they're not helpful for instance they're
going to they don't want to have the
fact that she's a training officer who
she trained in
but they may want to have the training
records that she had because maybe she
wasn't giving more training maybe she
had new taser
tasers and wasn't given more training on
that maybe the tasers malfunction i'm
sure they're also going to be looking at
that because you know the taser has
a laser to it right brian uh so they're
going to all looking at all of that
right now and i'm sure the judge is
going to be hearing motions on all of
that
yeah admissibility keeping things out
that's what we're going to be arguing
terry the trial is set for december 6.
the defense looks like it's going to
argue
mistake of fact could that work here
well it could but it's hard to believe
that a mistake of this taser and gun
because the difference between those two
devices
is so large the taser as we know is
yellow as far as the barrel is concerned
it's a different
weight and it's put on the non-dominant
side
i do think they're going to try to say
though that obviously
potter mistakened her you know taser
and and used the gun instead it sounds a
little bit like the
amber geiger case where she said that
she mistaken
botham's apartment for her own so i
think they're going to try to claim
that that was in fact the mistake of
fact and that's why
and she shouldn't be charged here yeah
it's gonna be interesting to see how
that plays out because from my
understanding my little
unlimited understanding it's a very
different mechanism to take the safety
off a gun
than it is to activate a taser that is
gonna be a hard hurdle for the defense
here we'll see how that works out coming
up on law and crime daily closing
arguments
from the trial of former florida deputy
zachary wester
plus a jury is now being selected in the
iowa trial
of a college student found murdered in a
cornfield a report from outside the
convention center where all the action
is happening when we come back
jury selection is underway in the iowa
trial of a man accused of murdering a
college student and leaving her body in
a cornfield
our angeletta levy is there for us and
explains how the process
is moving forward during the pandemic
we're in scott county iowa that's in
davenport where jury selection is
underway in the trial of
christian bahana rivera he's accused of
first degree murder in the death of
mollie tibbetts
tibbetts left her boyfriend's home in
brooklyn iowa back in july of 2018 she
went out jogging
and she never returned her boyfriend was
out of town on business and she was
staying at his home
watching his dogs a month later police
questioned christian bahina rivera after
noticing
a vehicle similar to his on surveillance
cameras in the area where tibbetts had
been running
and police and prosecutors say bahana
rivera confessed
to her killing and then dumping her body
in a cornfield
now the trial has been moved here to
scott county iowa that's in davenport
because of pre-trial publicity and
concerns
that the hana rivera wouldn't be able to
get a fair trial in the area where this
occurred
now jury selection is underway here at a
convention center
there's social distancing in place so
the jurors can be questioned
some of the jurors have been asked if
they formed strong opinions about the
case some have
and they were dismissed other jurors
have been questioned about whether or
not they believe
police can make mistakes and whether or
not they believe police are perfect
and whether that should impact a juror's
ability to find a defendant guilty so
this is a very high profile case
it's inflamed passions on both sides of
the immigration debate since christian
bahina rivera was an
undocumented immigrant at the time that
this murder took place
jury selection could take up to two days
and opening statements could be
presented
by wednesday in davenport iowa i'm
angelette levy for
law and crime daily thanks angeannette
when we come back the jury is out but
the verdict is not in
yet we take a closer look at the closing
arguments from the trial
of a former florida deputy on the other
side of this break
welcome back a florida jury is now
determining the fate of a former deputy
accused of planting drugs
on unsuspecting motorists
zachary wester is facing 67 charges
including racketeering
false imprisonment and perjury wester
took the stand in his own defense
and tonight allegations he planted drugs
on motorists during traffic stops
on monday morning the judge denied a
defense motion to dismiss the
racketeering charge
then both sides delivered closing
arguments prosecutors say the video is
clear
just look at the body cam video of
deputy wester planting drugs in teresa
odom's car
the most incredible thing about the odom
stop
is why in the world does the defendant
have palmed in his hand
which is clasped like this not like this
not like this
like this and you see it in the corner a
plastic baggie by his own admission
why in the world does he have that there
i would submit that this is objective
evidence
where you see him planting drugs in the
moment you see something in his hand
that has
no reason no logical reason given this
stop and what we know about it for it to
be there
this is him planting evidence and you
see it
his explanation about what is there is
not reasonable and makes
no sense
cross-examination i asked him are you
saying that you found this you say it
found it there
at what point the video do you stop to
look at what point of the video do you
make mention of it at what point in the
video
do you tell another officer about it at
what point you tell ms odom about it at
what point do you write it in report to
say it happen
there's a number we talked about numbers
and opening statement from the defense
zero it didn't happen
the defense went a different route in
their closings instead of addressing the
video of odom's arrest
they question the credibility of all the
witnesses
when you're weighing the evidence the
judge went over this with you
there's certain things that you know you
should look at beyond
you know obviously using your common
sense but he talks about
the instructions saying did the witness
seem to have an accurate memory
was the witness honest and
straightforward in answering the
attorney's questions
did the witness have some interest in
how the case should be decided
most of the people that got up there and
testified also said yeah
i'm suing i'm suing
at least one of them said yes a
conviction here would definitely help my
civil case
so is there an interest yes and what is
that money
let's bring in linda and terry one last
time
linda wester testified without a mask
you think he should have worn one why
because he was twitching and looking
threatening okay so
i put this mask on no one can see my i
can't see me twitching it but when you
get up there and you
and you're sniffling and a drug case as
you point out and you're going like this
and you're making all sorts of noises
and you you kind of have that like tough
guy cop look
you know he he really should he's one of
the people that should have put a mask
on because i think he
undercut what his attorney was doing i
mean a lot of our viewers especially on
youtube would agree with you that the
twitch of the nose with someone bothers
him especially in a drug case but what
did you make of the defense's arguments
and western testifying in this case
well i think the arguments were the best
they could make sure you're going to say
you're going to fall into exactly why
these people weren't believed in the
first place right because they're drunk
people
they had drugs they're going to get
money but then you're falling into like
blaming the victim aren't you but it's
the best he could do and when you have a
client who wants to testify
it's kind of like durst isn't it brian
who wants to testify we all know that
right
uh there's not much you can do as a
defense attorney they have to take the
stand and you let them take the stand
and they
either dig their own grave or they get
it not guilty yeah it's one of their
rights no lawyer anyone can stop them
from doing so if they want to testify
they testify
terry i know this is no sniffing matter
but in the closing arguments for the
prosecution
they suggested a number of motives that
he wanted to work narcotics
that he maybe even just liked the power
uh were these motives persuasive to you
you know it's no sniffing matter and
it's no laughing matter i do think they
were persuasive
i mean listen whenever you have a motive
that involves money even if it's not a
lot of money the fact that he was going
to make
a thousand dollars more that's enough
motive and
the fact that he wanted to go to a more
distinguished department
that is a motive and i actually think
because of
western's personality wanting the power
being able to
influence this power over people that he
thinks are more vulnerable
gives him some control so i absolutely
think there was
plenty of motive available here yeah and
when you think of motives and themes uh
uh linda's just real quickly some of the
ones that usually are like the biblical
ones the
trying to impress your father or trying
to live up to that mentality that makes
sense right
absolutely makes sense trying to undo
your past also from the prior department
brian exactly
thank you all for joining us here at law
on crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you